this island in the Indian Ocean supports
the riving seabird colonies and rich
coral reefs but nearby other islands are
eerily silent the cause of this
difference lies in a complex web of
birds rats
coral and poop the Chagos archipelago in
the Indian Ocean is home to over 60
tropical islands nearly a third of which
are completely free from invasive
species like rats or foxes this safe
haven for birds creates quite the
cacophony brother rat free Island
[Music]
[Music]
on neighboring islands however the
arrival of sailing ships in the 1800s
brought an unwanted visitor rats the
rodents prayers like wealth rodents they
devoured seabird eggs and chicks until
they all but wiped out the bird
populations in contrast to this island
where there's rats and there's very very
few seabirds the skies are empty and
it's very quiet
but the story doesn't stop there
because the birds play a critical role
in the wider ecosystem all thanks to
their poop now these birds return to the
islands when they roost and they breathe
huge mats wallow or bird poo come to the
islands and this swallow is highly rich
in nitrogen so they're effectively
fertilizing the islands this nitrogen is
great for plants which thrive on the
rat-free islands but scientists wondered
whether this aerial nitrogen delivery
system was also impacting the
surrounding coral reefs instead of
feeding on the algae out from the reef
crest we were able to look at their
growth rates the team found that
rat-free islands had two-and-a-half
times more nitrogen across the entire
ecosystem and fish living on the nearby
reefs grew faster and bigger than those
around rat-infested islands these fish
graze on algae that otherwise covers the
coral slowing its growth the scientists
observed three times more grazing on the
reefs surrounding rat-free islands these
healthier reefs may be more resilient to
climate change when it comes to
interwove and ecosystems like those of
the che cose archipelago
it seems invasive species like rats have
a bigger impact than we thought
so the erupting oceanic Islands should
really be a very high priority for
conservation it's not difficult to deer
up these islands and it would have a
huge
of the trusted environment and adjacent
rate environments the team is now urging
governments to consider investing in rat
extermination programs as a way to save
coral reefs this unusual solution could
be a quick and cost effective tool in
the fight against coral decline all due
to a complex chain linking rats birds
fish coral and poop
[Music]